y at il un manque de transparence sur
les contrats passés entre l'union
européenne et les laboratoires qui
développe un vaccin contre le coc u19
c'est ce que dénoncent plusieurs députés
européens sur les six entreprises
pharmaceutiques qui ont signé un contrat
avec bruxelles seul l'allemand curva qu
accepter la consultation de ces
documents mais sous certaines conditions
un contrat auquel les eurodéputés ont
accès depuis le 12 janvier pour quatre
heures par jour
un contrat avec de korvac de 225
millions de doses fermes et 180 millions
de doses optionnelles
on en parle tout de suite avec manuel
bompard député européen chef de la
délégation france insoumise au parlement
européen
bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france
donc est ce que vous vous avez pu
consulter justement ce rapport de
l'entreprise curva klassen a accepté de
dévoiler son contrat alors moi à titre
personnel non j'ai pas encore pu
consulter ce contrat mais un certain
nombre de mes collègues eurodéputés ont
pu le consulter
ils ont pu le consulter la bonne
nouvelle de la journée d'hier soir c'est
que le curve hague a annoncé qu' il
allait élargir la possibilité de
consultation en rendant le contrat
public en le publiant sur internet
une bonne nouvelle par contre ce qu'il
va toujours pas c'est que en fait le
contrat qui est rendue publique ou celui
que les eurodéputés pouvez consulter
c'est un contrat qui est incomplet dans
lequel un certain nombre d'éléments ont
été retirés et notamment on considère
que en tout cas c'est ce que montrent
les personnes qui ont pu voir le contrat
qui a normalement si klose qui concerne
la responsabilité en cas de décès
secondaire sur les vaccins et que deux
d'entre elles ont été tout simplement
supprimée du contrat donc on a une
petite progression sur la question de la
transparence mais elle est très
clairement insuffisante et puis surtout
pour l'instruire que cure bac et donc
contrairement aux engagements de la
commission européenne l'ensemble les
autres contrats sont pour l'instant
secret et n'ont pas été rendus publics
pour ce que vous nous expliquer c'est
que dans les consultations il ya des
clauses du contrat justement qui ont été
enlevés
de manière précise oui oui effectivement
comme je le disais les cyclos des deux
qui ont été retirés et ce qui pose un
problème parce que il ya notamment une
question autour de ces contrastes ça
aussi il existe des clauses de
responsabilité c'est à dire est ce qu en
cas d'effets secondaires non désirées
sur les vaccins qui doit indemniser qui
doit payer et c'est klose il semble que
certaines d'entre elles mais on ne peut
pas les voir disque dans le cas d'effets
secondaires ce sont des états qui
doivent indemniser les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques pour l'indemnisation des
patients qui auraient été frappés par
des effets secondaires et ça il ya une
vraie question sur le sujet parce que la
commissaire européenne à la santé qui
s'appelle madame qui avait acquis des
salles dit qu'il y avait effectivement
ce type de clause alors que la ministre
française madame manière une hache et
nous dit non pas du tout il n'y a pas
ces clauses dans le contrat
donc la meilleure manière de le savoir
ça serait de pouvoir consulter les
contrats dans leur intégralité
ce qui nous est malheureusement pour
l'instant refusé confiant à l'été sur
les effets du vaccin alors il ya
d'autres firmes father biotech moderna
dont les vaccins sont autorisés en
europe mais aussi sanofi
astrazeneca johnson & johnson qui sont
entrés en négociation avec la commission
européenne
ces firmes elles gardent leur contrat
pour elle pour quelles raisons selon
vous ben je ne sais pas pour quelle
raison j'imagine c'est pour protéger des
éléments de négociation mais c'est
quelque chose qui ne peut pas être
rentable pour nous parce que la
commission européenne quand elles
signent ce type de contrat elle agir au
nom des citoyens de l'union européenne
et donc elle doit rendre des comptes et
la manière de rendre des comptes et de
rendre publics les conditions de cette
négociation
or aujourd'hui on est dans une situation
où en notre nom à nous on a passé des
contrats avec les labos pharmaceutiques
nez on ne sait pas ce qu'il ya dans ces
contrats eh ben je crois que c'est pas
acceptable et je crois que c'est aussi
une raison pour laquelle il ya une
défiance très importante en france au
sein de l'union européenne des citoyens
vis-à-vis des vaccins
les gens ils sont pas par principe
contre les vaccins mais il s'interroge
sur est ce que les vaccins ne sont pas
devenus une manière pour ces labos
pharmaceutiques de s'en mettre plein les
poches et c'est pourquoi en tant que
député européen avec d'autres députés
européens on a soutenu une initiale
citoyenne européenne qui demande à ce
que finalement les brevets des cons des
vaccins sont amis dans le domaine public
que n'importe quel labos pharmaceutiques
puisse se mettre à produire les vaccins
s'il le souhaite parce que au moins ces
vaccins ne seront plus une manière de se
faire de l'argent mais bien une manière
de répondre à un enjeu de santé publique
il ya un enjeu d'intérêt général ce
serait une manière de permettre à tout
le monde de pouvoir produire des vaccins
et puis ce serait une manière aussi de
faciliter l'accès aux vaccins des pays
les plus pauvres de la planète
aujourd'hui si on achète toutes les deux
au sein de l'union européenne il y aura
à peu près 3 2 par citoyens européens
mais si le salaire en afrique du sud
aujourd'hui il ya une dose pour trois
citoyens de l'afrique du sud parce que
en fait seuls les pays riches ont accès
à ces vaccins
donc la seule manière de répondre et de
résoudre ce problème c'est de faire en
sorte qu'ils aient un accès universel
aux vaccins d'ailleurs le président
macron s'était engagée sur le sujet
l'été dernier et pour le temps alors je
souhaitais pas olivier ferrand sur
demande d'emmanuelle macron promet de
publier le nombre des doses de vaccins
disponibles en france en toute
transparence votre réaction
ce serait un élément de transparence
important effectivement mais encore une
fois pas suffisant c'est pas seulement
le nombre de doses qu'il faut publier
c'est effectivement le prix auquel on
les a achetés et puis c'est aussi
effectivement des éléments secrets qui
peuvent exister dans l'est dans les
contrats mais de manière le plus général
plus générale la faillite dans la
logistique de l'êta en france
aujourd'hui elle n'est pas due au fait
qu'on n'ait pas publié le nombre de
doses c'est que il ya des gens qui
souhaitent se faire vacciner moi je suis
pas pour l'obligation vaccinale mais il
faut que quand on souhaite se faire se
faire vacciner on puisse l'être et
meilleurs délais aujourd'hui vous avez
des doses en france qui dorment dans des
frigos
je pense que c'est pas acceptable
manuellement par cette dernière question
pour revenir justement au contrat passé
avec la commission européenne cette
commission européenne est ce que
gagne-t-elle justement
vis-à-vis de ce manque de transparence
présumés ce qui a des choses à cacher on
en revient encore à ce qu'il disait tout
à l'heure
concernant les conditions de
consultation des contrats non moi je
pense qu'elle ne gagne rien mais que la
commission européenne elle se fait
dicter sa loi par des industries
pharmaceutiques qui sont aujourd'hui en
position de force parce qu'elles peuvent
dire ben si vous mettez des conditions
de publicité des contrats bon on vous
donne pas les vaccins et c'est pourquoi
je disais que kelly une grande
importance à supprimer et a demandé que
dans le cadre de la coupe pandémie de
kobe de 19
les brevets sur les contrats et les
traitements ça supprime et que tous amis
dans le domaine public parce que alors
n'enlèverait dans le rapport de force 7
cette arme dont disposent les conduit
les labos pharmaceutiques pour nous
faire payer le vaccin à des prix très
important et puis pour nous faire payer
éventuellement d d d d effets
secondaires des indemnisations pour les
effets secondaires
il faut pas laisser les labos
pharmaceutiques la loi voilà le message
que moi j'en vois la commission
européenne
je suis pas le seul et une grande
majorité au parlement européen pour
demander enfin la transparence sur ces
contrats il est temps qu'elle devienne
effective
merci beaucoup à vous manuel bompard
député européen chef de la délégation
france
insoumise au parlement européen